Hi, my name is Matt Cutts and I work in Google Search Quality Group.
Today, I'm gonna tell you a bit about how Google Social Search works.
Google Social Search is a new experiment to help you find publicly available Web content...
...from your social circle quickly and more easily in Google Search.
First, let me give you some context.
Today on the Internet, people have many different places where they make social connections...
...and publish web content like blogs, status updates, Tweets and pictures.
People choose to publish much of this content publicly for everyone to see.
For example, I have a Twitter account where I follow more than a hundred people.
Anyone browsing on the Web today can visit my Twitter page and see the Tweets I've been writing.
Anyone can also see the list of people I'm following on Twitter.
I also write a public blog, and have a FriendFeed account.
These various online social services create an implicit network of connections...
...which we like to call, your social circle.
For example, I'm following Leo Laporte on Twitter,...
...and on FriendFeed, I follow Danny Sullivan.
There's also an extended social circle...
...which is the set of people that Leo and Danny follow.
With Google Social Search, we've managed to pull...
...different pieces of your public social circle together in a single place.